We have people coming into our country
that are looking to do tremendous harm.
Exactly.
One year ago today,
I did my best to explore the way Donald
Trump answers a question.
His use of language in speech I thought
was fascinating and unique and
illuminated.
Why he's so successful at selling a
feeling now that trump has been
president elect for 50 days.
We don't get to hear much of trump's
speech anymore.
His interview appearances are dwindling
and his press conferences or
nonexistent,
but that doesn't mean he stopped using
and manipulating language these days.
The language that trump puts on the
public record and comes largely from
writing,
specifically from writing on twitter in
140 character notes as of December 29th,
2016,
trump has tweeted 221 times as the
president elect.
It's important to note at the outset
that these tweets come largely from a
few sources.
Thanks to info from the metadata.
We know that of the 221,
153 or 69 percent come from an android
phone.
Trump's personal samsung galaxy 59 or 27
percent come from an iphone and nine or
four percent come from the twitter web
client as in someone typing the tweets
into a computer.
A number of commentators and data
analysts have surmised that the iphone
tweets are not written by trump himself,
but by his staff.
I think that's almost certainly true.
If you look at those tweets exclusively,
you capture all of the announcements and
cabinet picks as well as the holiday
messages and the notes of condolence of
those 59 tweets,
49 share links or are retweets and all
or almost all of them are likely written
by Dan Scavino,
trump's director of social media or Brad
Parscale,
a website designer turned high level
staffer who trump and trusted with
tweeting for him during the presidential
debates of the 153 tweets that come from
trump's personal samsung.
Not One shares a link,
so that's a good rule of thumb.
If you want to determine which tweets
are from him and which aren't.
The huge majority of the android tweets
are trump's personal thoughts or
reactions.
Then you can split them up in a few
ways.
For example,
40 of those are positive were
congratulatory and tone.
Ninety four are negative or critical in
tone and 19 are pretty much neutral like
in a speech.
One thing trump is really,
really good at is emotionally framing
his tweets and most of them are
emotionally charged,
which is why 87 percent of them are
negative or positive in tone.
Trump doesn't want a sympathetic reader
to spend any time at all the ciphering,
how to feel about what he's saying.
A lot of people have mocked the way he
concludes tweets with one or two word
exclamations like sad or too bad,
but these punctuations are actually
powerful framing devices that lubricate
the content of his message.
They also reflect a key insight that
trump has knowingly or unknowingly about
twitter and texting as a form of
communication.
While tweets are technically a kind of
writing,
scholars have long theorize that
computer mediated communication more
closely resembles speech than writing
were funky punctuation substitutes for
conversational cues.
For example,
every time you see someone extend toward
by adding letters saying,
I'm so sad,
or I love breaking bad,
what they're essentially doing is trying
to transmit some emotional content that
would have existed in face to face
conversation,
instant messages,
text messages and tweets attract these
speech like qualities and Donald trump
understands this.
While he doesn't extend words with extra
letters,
his punctuation at the end of tweets are
extremely speech.
Slide 50,
one of his 153 personal tweets end with
exclamations like this.
In [inaudible] 95,
there was at least one exclamation
point.
Whereas opponents and other politicians
right through twitter,
trump speaks through.
Instead of asking us to read,
he forces us to here,
but all of this begs the important
question,
what's the point?
Trump is no longer a candidate.
He doesn't have to persuade us to vote
for him.
I mean,
you could spend a lot of time looking at
a tweet like this from the president
elect of the United States scratching
your head and you could wonder about the
message or the distraction it causes
were the headlines that generates,
but if that's the way you think,
this man will always baffled you.
Trump doesn't resemble other politicians
on twitter.
He resembles the rest of us.
He resembles that person you know on
facebook who was posting all the time
about how happy they are.
Nice people don't tweet or post because
they're trying to relay relevant
information.
They do it to carefully craft their own
identities against some imagined
audience that exists only to reinforce
what they need to believe.
The media and the public act like
trump's tweets contain messages that
were meant to receive when the truth is,
I think that he's not thinking of us at
all.
When you look at it through this lens,
trump's twitter account makes a lot more
sense.
It makes sense that a lot of his
congratulatory tweets are self
congratulatory and his negative tweets,
which account for an astounding majority
are personal in their attacks and sense
of victimization,
and it makes sense that we should react
to it so strongly.
We're all in this age of social media,
intimately familiar with this kind of
behavior.
We do it ourselves every day.
What we're not familiar with not yet at
least is this kind of thing from the
most powerful person in the world.
How it will fall out when you hold a
position where even your words
desperately tweeted into the void,
have global impact,
but give it time and we will be.
There are going to be tons more at nerd
writer episodes in 2017.
So if you want to join this crazy thing
that I started five years ago,
you can click that box right over there
and subscribe to channel and you'll
get all the videos.
I really am so excited for next year.
I want to level up the show,
make content that you have not seen
anywhere else on youtube or the rest of
the world,
and I'm really excited to bring that to
you guys.
I'm working really hard to do it.
I have to think crunchy roll for
sponsoring this episode.
If you really love anime shows,
which I do and you can't find what
you're looking for on Netflix,
you can go to control.
It's like the Netflix of animated.
They have hd episodes,
thousands of titles,
something areas in Japan.
You can get it an hour later on.
Crunchy roll.
I want to recommend attack on Titan,
which is super,
super weird show,
but an amazing show I can pitch you.
Love it.
Um,
if you use [inaudible] dot com slash
nerd writing and get 30 day free trial
and watch that show and let me know what
you think of the comments.
Thank you guys so much.
I will see all of you next year.
I'm so excited.